this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by big wave
surfer laird hamilton and volleyball
champion gabby reese layered superfood
that's l-a-i-r-d delivers high-impact
fuel to help you get through your
busiest days and i know these two people
they walk the walk i love their new
aloha oat mac you heard me right aloha
oatmak superfood creamer i use the
unsweetened version made from real
plant-based ingredients including
organic oats macadamia nuts that's where
the oat mac comes from avocado oil and
aquaman aquaman is a natural source of
seaweed derived calcium with 72 minerals
and trace amounts laird's creamers can
really optimize your daily coffee or tea
ritual i use them all the time and a 10
bag will last you a long time for a
limited time lyric superfood is offering
you guys my listeners 20 off when you
use code tim
20 at checkout that's tim20
visit
layeredsuperfood.com tim to see some of
my favorite products and learn more
again that's lairdsuperfood.com
tim l-a-i-r-d layered superfood.com and
use code tim20 for 20 off of your order
layeredsuperfood.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by
givewell i love these guys donating
money to help other people is wonderful
but how can you be confident that your
donations are actually doing things are
they improving or saving lives
effectively it can be really hard to
parse you could do weeks of research to
find the charities that are out there
what programs they run what their admin
overhead is how effective blah blah blah
on and on it can take forever i know
from experience doing the research is
really hard
or you could simply visit givewell.org
for a short vetted list of the charities
they've found to be best per dollar in
donations at saving or improving lives
givewell spends more than 20 000 hours
each year researching charitable
organizations and only recommends a few
of the highest impact evidence-backed
charities they've found they do all of
this without any sign-up fees and
without taking a cut of your tax
deductible donation givewell wants to
empower as many donors as possible to
make informed decisions about their
donations so give well is free i've
recommended givewell.org for a while now
and donations from listeners of this
podcast that's you guys amount now to
roughly
hundred ninety 483
dollars and twenty seven cents so close
to five hundred thousand dollars which
is incredible so first and foremost
thanks to everyone who has donated in
total more than fifty thousand people
have used givewell to donate as
effectively as possible and rigorous
evidence suggests that these donations
will save tens of thousands of lives and
improve the lives of millions more so go
right now to givewell.org and when you
make your first donation your gift will
be matched up to 250
this matching offer is good for as long
as the funds last so it's time sensitive
and is a great opportunity to multiply
your impact which is something i always
look for how can i get the maximum
multiplicative effect out of my dollars
that i give
to participate just go to givewell.org
and when you get to check out pick
podcast and enter tim ferriss show it's
that simple so one more time get your
first donation matched up to 250 at
givewell.org be sure to select podcast
and tim ferriss show at checkout
at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake can i answer your personal
questions
[Music]
[Music]
hello boys and girls this is tim ferriss
and welcome to another episode of the
tim ferriss show my guest today is henry
shukman
s-h-u-k-m-i-n you can find him on
instagram at mountain cloud zen center
henry teaches mindfulness and awakening
practices to a wide range of students
from all traditions and walks of life
henry is an appointed teacher in the
[ __ ] zen lineage and is the guiding
teacher of mountain cloud zen center he
was introduced to me by my very close
friend kevin rose that is how this came
to be he has an m.a from cambridge and
an amulet from saint andrews and has
written several award-winning books of
poetry and fiction his essays have been
published in the new york times outside
and tricycle and his poems have been
published in the new republic guardian
sunday times that's in the uk and london
review of books henry has taught
meditation at google harvard business
school ubs eslin institute colorado
college united world college and many
other venues he has written of his own
journey in his latest book one blade of
grass subtitle finding the old road of
the heart a zen memoir and that book was
gifted to me by the aforementioned kevin
rose affectionately known as kev kev on
this podcast very often
the website is
mountaincloud.org you can find
both henry and mountain cloudsen center
on instagram at mountain cloud zen
center facebook facebook.com
mtn cloudzen and you can find henry on
linkedin linkedin.com i n henry hyphen
shookman
s-h-u-k-m-a-n henry welcome back to the
show i promised everyone around too i
promised myself around too because i
have all of these notes that we didn't
even touch
in the last conversation which was
wide-ranging and i want to focus on
koans and delve deeply into many
remaining questions about zen and
practices and so on and i thought we
might start
as i mentioned before we started
recording with a live
example a real world case study and that
is
i'm coming down with some kind of cold
i've got a scratchy throat
i feel turbulent
in my internal state right now because i
was
feeling a little sick also got agitated
earlier this morning and that has
continued to the present moment so i'm
wondering
when you have a lot going on or life has
thrown you a curveball or who knows just
wake up on the wrong side of the bed
assuming that still happens occasionally
what do you do
with
your toolkit and training and so on what
happens
okay okay thank you so much for asking
that i like it a lot and it's dear to my
heart because alas i do have to deal
with that you know it's not gone as
perhaps it ought to have in some
marvelously you know awakened
practitioner or something but i'm
evidently not there yet so i can
definitely i think i can offer a few
tools but actually i want to just say
i've got to say this tim thank you
very much for having me back i'm kind of
bowled over actually amazed and i know
you said it last time but i thought
somehow it'll just get postponed and
won't happen because i mean
you know you have the people you have on
are just so sort of amazing and i'm
unknown and and weird so
you know it's it's a real sort of my
sweet spot actually
but it's it's like i kid in part it's
it's great to have you back on and thank
you for saying that and uh had to have
you back on i promised it
well
i really am sort of humbled and very
grateful so let's see
yeah so i can totally relate to your
question about where you're at right now
i mean actually to be honest i can
relate because i've got
i'm in the situation i'm in right now
first of all talking to tim ferriss my
god but then secondly actually i've got
to do a teaching tonight to something
like 400 people as a guest teacher and
so that's a little bit sort of in my
system and tomorrow morning
my wife and i are flying back to the uk
for
just under two weeks the first time in
two years or more to see our aging aging
parents who we haven't been able to be
face to face with in person
my system is uh is sort of it knows all
that that's going on
now you've got a cold or something
coming on you had some kind of should we
call it sort of a triggering event or
some kind of activating event kerfuffle
earlier today yes
okay
yeah right so the system got sort of a
little bit riled up and hasn't fully
settled down again it has not settled
down at all
i appreciate the generous phrasing but
yes
okay well look i mean first of all
let's acknowledge clearly that that's
the situation
there's a system here with a little bit
of up regulation the sediment is
churning
yes
so that's the first thing is just to
know it to state it to be clear about it
this is what i do and then the second
thing
i mean really the key to the whole thing
is letting it be that way
it's like
okay
here's a highly sensitive creature
a human being
and
among human beings some
by temperament have more sensitivity
than others
all of us have fluctuations in our
levels of sensitivity
and some of us
do i mean in a sense do
the kind of inner work that leads to
more sensitivity
let's note that in a way to be sensitive
to things is a good thing
it means that we're more aware
of
life
but very broadly but with it comes the
possibility of getting more easily riled
up
those of us who've had
for whatever reasons and whatever shape
traumatic
elements in our childhoods
especially also if we are of a
sensitive nature
that sort of it comes into us it's it's
a wound that you know is in us
so
when we're allowing ourselves to be in
let's say an agitated or a somehow
distressed
state when we're allowing that
it helps to also allow
with compassion
that you know
somehow things have made us
be sensitive like this and we're still
we still know we know that we still have
wounds
and maybe
in some sense there's a core wound
and we don't want to close that off
and one way to not close it off is to be
ready to accept and allow our states of
agitation and distress in the present
moment
if we can do that
and see how in a way it's a kind of um
if it's allowed
it becomes a kind of
opening to perhaps a sort of deeper
wound
at least there's some recognition that
that's there too
and both are allowed
that we have as well as having
that stuff
we also have
all of us come
pre-installed
with access to a sort of wider
more loving
in this case really meaning more
self-loving
awareness
our hearts
have the capacity to love ourselves
and we need to tap into that henry may i
jump in for one second please please
please i would love to be a dork and ask
some technical questions about this word
allowing
so when you allow
these feelings to exist or you allow
yourself to recognize
and accept your current state so allow
and accept these are the two words i
have questions about
how would you describe
how that manifests for instance like
what is
the self-talk or
what
do you do with the feelings
in other words if you were to try to
describe for someone what
not accepting or not allowing
looks like and what allowing and
accepting look like on the other hand
what are the characteristics of those
two things like practically for people
listening if they're like great i want
to allow and accept how do i do that
what does it look like again i'll tell
you what i do but remember this is on
the back of decades of
being still a bit each day because
really the i'd say like the the ideal is
like this that we can be still
we might close our eyes
and be still
and
first say
wow i'm agitated i'm distressed maybe
i'm a bit overwhelmed
if that's appropriate
acknowledge it state it
to declare it
what do they say to name it is to tame
it
i've never heard that i like that yeah
it makes it a little bit easier if we
can just identify what's going on
in a clear
kind matter of fact internal voice
i'm feeling a bit overwhelmed
i'm feeling a bit agitated
i'm feeling somewhat distressed
okay so the first thing is stating it
now
there's forks in the road all the way
along so lots of ways of doing this but
let's say
for somebody who's got a certain amount
of sort of
somatic awareness that's to say we can
find feelings in the body i've actually
heard you on a podcast saying i don't
know how old the podcast was that like
you get the throat and not much else
kind of thing so has that have you done
work on the somatic stuff at all like
feeling things in the body
i have i feel like for all the
sensitivities that i have in so many
other places i don't want to say that
i'm physically insensitive but when
when i'm in say a comey therapy session
which is really as
if i could simplify it a
semantic-focused
mindfulness practice it's constantly
answering the question what are you
feeling
but in great detail
and
i don't think i have a great vocabulary
for it maybe that's part of the handicap
yeah
because someone could say i feel
like
my friend is being unreasonable and it's
like well it's not really a feeling what
are the actual kinesthetic
sensations and i would say i'm probably
a step
broader than just tightness in the
throat there's more to it than that
but
i wouldn't say i've seen group sessions
where exercises are being done and
someone can go on for five minutes in
like a mini ted talk of their
bodily sensations i do not do that
okay okay
okay let's just see like right now and i
don't know if you if you would be happy
to close your eyes but it's usually a
bit easier if you do i will close my
eyes yes i can
i can comply with that
this is very good i hope everyone is
sort of okay with this and if by the way
i suppose if anybody's driving don't
follow along right
i mean if we have to tell you that also
like
seriously
be careful with natural selection but uh
yes if you if you're driving don't close
your eyes if you're operating heavy
machinery don't close your eyes in other
words consult with your closest common
sense phd please
yes i will i will close my eyes and
share my experience with the audience so
okay we'll keep it to that
so let's see so we're sitting you can
feel the seat of the chair
let yourself just feel that let yourself
feel your feet on the floor
whatever your hands are doing just feel
them as well
it doesn't matter whether they're
free-floating or holding each other or
resting on the thighs or something it
doesn't matter resting on a desk
just feel them
and again feel the feet
and again feel the seat
see if you can feel all three
zones at once hands
feet and seat
and you don't have to do anything
special it's just
just kind of recognizing that they're
there
as sensations
and
just let me check in is that is that
sort of working for you feeling them
i am and i i should probably clarify
that
one thing i feel very
capable of i have a lot of sensitivity
for
is feeling
different parts of my body so if i
wanted to take the kind of locus of my
conscious awareness and put it in my
like right big toe or in my left
achilles tendon this type of practice
that we're doing right now i am very
comes very easily to me
okay and i don't want to interrupt the
flow so please keep track but when
people usually ask in a therapy session
what are you feeling in your body
they're wanting to sort of tie it to
some emotional tenor and that's where i
have
a harder time but yes i can feel i can
easily pay attention to the sensation of
my hands on the table
my feet on the ground and
my ass on this very very hard white
chair that i'm sitting on
okay
well that's i mean honestly that's
probably nine tenths of the battle so to
speak sweet that's the key thing look so
let's just we'll keep on with this so
we've got
feet we've got hands we've got seat
if you've got any back to the chair
maybe your lower back or something is
just touching that as well just feel
that if it is it's fine if it is or
isn't now let's go to the shoulders just
feel them
let them settle a bit
let them kind of uh
as it were sort of slump on their
sockets kind of thing
let's feel the jaw now
so here's a key thing it's really great
to slacken the jaw
it's a common thing in in our
sort of fast-paced world our sort of
hasty world
to have tightness in the jaw
so
see if you can let the jaw sink
about an eighth of an inch
probably forward and down
and see if that at the same time brings
some kind of softness into the throat
and you might also just bring your
attention to your tongue
because the tongue is you know it's a
massive muscle that's incredibly it's
full of micro muscles it's incredibly
busy
let it rest right now
i know you're gonna have to be talking
shortly but it's okay to rest it
let it
settle on the floor of your mouth
and maybe you get a sense it sort of
lightly expands
like a if you're camping and you leave
your down sleeping bag in a
sunny tent all day it kind of inflates
let your tongue do that just for a few
seconds
maybe you're getting a sort of
little enveloping kind of just little
taste of softness like almost a soft
cloud
around tongue or our throat jaw
all of them easing becoming easier
so i'm just going to check in are you
getting anything like this
yeah i'm following along
definitely great okay so we're still
with that softness in that area
now we're going to let it melt down
so it melts down into the shoulders
and the arms by the way become really
limp
and it melts on down into the upper
chest
middle chest lower chest
and then right through and around the
midriff kind of the
solar plexus area right in the middle of
the body either side of it and whatever
to some extent through it down into the
upper belly
middle belly
lower belly seat
upper legs lower legs feet all becoming
quite kind of
maybe a bit warm and soft
so now
already we're
getting a bit more balanced in ourselves
probably already a little bit calmer
likely
we hope
yeah yeah and a bit more sort of easy
and in this state of mind where we've
managed to sort of diffuse a certain
ease
all through the body and we you know
under other conditions we might take
longer with this and go a little more
minutely just to really
tasting the quality of ease
and now
we can bring our attention
to
sort of the whole
atmosphere
around the heart don't go for the middle
of the heart just sort of the whole
area around the heart if the chest was a
kind of snow globe you know and the
heart was a little structure in the
bottom in the middle of the snow globe
we want to be aware of the whole snow
globe
you know those little things you shake
and snowfalls you know what i mean i do
i hope you do yeah good okay so that
whole area
so just feeling
how is
this whole area
and it might be that
much of it is relatively sort of clear
maybe sort of spacious and the parts of
it are a bit contracted and tight
with some tension in them
could be that there's also if we go a
little lower in the body like the solar
plexus like right in the middle
above the belly and below the chest kind
of thing
around there there's often some
tightness some contraction
so we're going to be aware of any
tension contraction we're finding
and we're not going to try to change it
instead we're gonna be soft around it
we're just gonna let a real get a sense
of the body the fabric tissue of the
body actually softening
to the sides
of the chest the sides of the flanks
and whatever there may be by way of
tension
more in the middle of the body of middle
of the trunk
the intention is
to allow it to be there
this is the allowing
in a slightly more somatic sense
we're softening around it and welcoming
it
and allowing it meaning
yes
you're welcome
you're welcome to be here
that's the kind of vibe
i welcome you
i want to treat you tenderly
i want to be kind to you
i know that i'm a sensitive creature
i know that i'm a suffering being
and my intention isn't to try to
eradicate that or
deny that or banish that
exile that no or reject that no
my intention is to welcome this
and i know i'm maybe imperfect at it but
i'm trying
and i want you
little tension little tightness little
contraction
to know that i'm welcoming you
and
ah
maybe there's just a little more ease
in
finding
that at least there's a kind of sense of
vague possibility of doing this
in other words you don't have to be
rejecting
your feelings
now we're looking at feelings right now
in a very somatic way
we're not so interested in any of the
storylines
any of the cognitive side of emotion
we're
really just
feeling it out in the body okay now tim
i've been going on quite a while how's
this going you can stay in it as you're
reporting or you can just pop out
whichever you prefer oh it's great it's
like a therapy
session that i don't have to pay for
it's fantastic i
and without the
cognitive overlay of the story so this
is i imagine
we're about 20 minutes in
this is 20 minutes that i could listen
to very regularly and i could use your
it's the right word maleficent
maleficent this is a word i have to find
this is a word that my fancy gre friend
used once
melith mellifluous yeah maleficent yeah
i think you nailed it that's the one
sweet or musical pleasant to hear the
voice was mellifluous and smooth
so as i was saying without any type of
hesitancy in my vocabulary
listening to your mellifluous voice for
20 minutes but moreover the
kinesthetic
focusing and relaxing without story is
actually
really effective for calming my system
and it's a contrast to what i struggle
with which often exacerbates the
situation which is
for instance perhaps i'm asked like
which of the
five dominant emotions are you feeling
joy anger sadness etc and there's a list
now where are you feeling that emotion
those are questions that are
the second in particular very hard for
me to answer
but
the sequencing is like sort of boot up
or boot down or scanning sequence that
we just did
really calm my system without
any
labeling
of
emotion
right well i mean you know part of me
wants to say sort of welcome to the male
gender
i mean we're sort of notoriously poorly
socialized or poorly educated in our
socialization in having any emotional
literacy at all i feel that by the time
i was
cognizant that there was such a thing as
emotion all i knew was kind of i'm
feeling okay and i'm feeling awful i
couldn't pass out whether i would
whether it was
i like like mad glad sad afraid i find
that very easy to remember
yeah right there's four primary emotions
i don't know i know people have
different lists i think four is quite
good because
it's just so easy to remember mad glad
sad afraid and i wouldn't have a clue
what i mean of course if i was feeling
glad i'd sort of
i'd know that i wasn't feeling awful but
that was about the extent of my
emotional literacy so
god i think for many guys
i hope it's okay to talk like this it's
a journey well i'll i'll take this
episode and i'll put it on my new
podcast which is actually called poorly
socialized so you'll be okay on that
podcast
please please continue
so you know it's it's not surprising for
many of us that we
we really have to go on a journey that
might take some time to start to
understand
in any sense really understand our
emotional life and it's it's so critical
because what can you do with emotions
negative emotions difficult emotions if
you don't know what they are other than
try to banish them
and you know if we try to banish them
we're sort of
inevitably we're banishing part of
ourself or parts it just doesn't work
and it's
the type of realization that i would
have thought by now i would have
translated to
consistent reliable
self-relating do you know what i mean
like i i know that divorcing a part of
yourself and stuffing or
refusing feelings doesn't work
i know it just leads to more problems
and yet
here we are again you know the dog
chasing its tail once again once again
right but you know we have to sort of
compassionately bear in mind
what happened to us
in childhood because
for many of us that lays down some kind
of a template for how we're going to
handle difficult emotions and if we have
things that are really
basically too much for us to handle in
childhood and we're alone trying to
handle these difficult feelings without
support without
being
met by anybody without connection to
anybody it's overwhelming and there's
kind of no choice it's like
either i
die and often for an infant especially
it seems like it is life or death
or i
somehow
have to
make it so i don't feel this somehow
then we may have
caregivers who chastise us for showing
emotion
we may have stressed parents who just
can't handle it they don't need another
screaming
toddler or infant they've got so much on
their plate already
and who knows what and so
i think it's it's not surprising that
that we would ongoingly
have to be working on this stuff
but i mean the good news as far as i'm
concerned is that
inside of these difficulties i think
there's ways to access
well i don't know god we're going i'm
going off the deep end again like last
time but um i think that's why i'm
having you back on so
okay well
for a
okay i guess so okay i'll go all in the
inside of many of us i believe there's
some kind of deep primordial wound
there's some deep ancient grief i don't
know partly it's probably part of the
human race and all the things it's been
through over thousands of generations
and all the killing and famine and
slavery and things the most painful
things that have gone on endless loss of
children so many difficult things human
beings have been through
but somehow i think most of us probably
i mean i don't know i don't know whether
you could ever scientifically prove this
but i suspect that anyway a lot of us
have got some deep grief inside us and
actually
there are various methods i think a lot
of good therapists somehow
tap into that or can find ways to kindly
gently
give us opportunities to sort of open up
to that
and it can be incredibly cathartic and
incredibly healing actually
to open in that kind of way and find
that grief
is not an enemy personally i feel that
some of the most significant
most important sort of pivot points in
my my growth so far
as a fallible ailing [ __ ] up human
being has been
has been through things like that when
suddenly a gate of my heart opened and i
could feel all this grief
but somehow in that grief i could also
feel
just great love and
i don't know how this works exactly but
my hunch is that
grief and love and hurt and love and
pain and love
they're joined at the hip somehow
and so
our acts i mean i have gone deeper than
with like how to handle and know
emotions but yeah it all relates really
if we allow our emotional challenges and
tightness and and reluctance and to feel
if we're given a supportive framework
where we can open to that then we might
open to this sort of deeper
well of grief and
it's so beautiful because then we find
wow
in the depths of this somehow i don't
feel so alone
there's a truth in this that somehow
joins me to the human race or something
like that i don't know maybe i'm getting
off the rails here not only off the deep
end but off the rails
but there's something here you know for
us i really think this is a part of our
healing
that's been anyway my experience
and so
not being afraid
of
feelings
is
a really important starting point and
that is i think part of the
allowing piece
you know is that
instead of
feeling this way being wrong and bad and
i gotta not feel this way
kind of flip it
i'm gonna allow this to teach me
something
i don't really
know what it is and it's probably quite
hard for me to believe it could teach me
anything it just seems like wrong but
actually maybe it's not wrong maybe it's
just that
my map of myself has
got
a lot of terror incognito
unknown lands in my map of myself and
hey why don't i
allow
myself to be on a journey of discovery
of not knowing all of who i am
and being willing to let
part of myself show themselves that i
didn't think i wanted to know or didn't
even think we're there to be known
but maybe they are
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show this episode is brought to you by
linkedin jobs today many small business
owners like me are busier than ever time
spent searching for and interviewing
candidates can take time away from
managing and most importantly growing
your business that's why linkedin jobs
has made it easier to get to the
candidates worth interviewing faster and
for free create a free job post in
minutes on linkedin jobs to reach your
network and beyond to the world's
largest professional network of more
than 770 million people focus on
candidates with the skills and
experience you need and use screening
questions to get your role in front of
only the most qualified people then use
the simple tools on linkedin jobs to
quickly filter and prioritize who you'd
like to interview and hire it's why
small businesses rate linkedin jobs
number one in delivering quality hires
over leading competitors linkedin jobs
helps you find the candidates worth
interviewing faster did you know every
week nearly 40 million job seekers visit
linkedin
so try it out post your job for free at
linkedin.com
tim tim that's linkedin.com
tim to post your job for free terms and
conditions do apply
you know i was
listening to you of course
one would hope
just now and what i heard you say was
given your
more sophisticated accent the queen's
english and such i heard terror
incognita and
i thought to myself you know that's
actually then i realized of course that
you're saying terra incognita as i would
say and i was like well maybe to get to
the terra incognita the undiscovered
territory or the unexplored territory
where one reaps the rewards you have to
go through the terror incognito
just the fear in the middle but i'm
starting to really i'm grasping at
straws here so let me try to land this
plane if that's okay just yeah yeah yeah
totally just so we can pile on as many
mixed metaphors as possible
this has been extremely helpful i want
to sit with this we may come back to it
but i want to make sure that i cover a
topic that is of great interest to me it
is of great interest to our mutual
friend kevin rose
and
there are a number of words that you
brought up that led me to think about it
framework truth
especially framework is not something
that most people would associate with
koan the word koan or the
what people might think of as koans and
i think we should start from scratch
because not everyone will have heard the
first episode but
before ever
speaking to kevin about
some of what he's learned
i didn't know that koans which we'll
define in a minute have checking
questions that there may be such a thing
as passing or not passing a koan which
kind of blew my mind because
for me and perhaps you could give an
example but what is the sound of one
hand clapping
that may or may not be a real example
that there may be some some nuance to to
that or
one that i had kind of booked marked for
myself which is is somewhat different
maybe which is not knowing is most
intimate which again may or may not be a
real koan you could you can certainly
clarify but these are
statements of paradox that are
intended to be meditated upon as a way
of
perhaps stepping outside the confines of
logical rational
hyper-intellectualized
existence maybe that's how i would look
at these types of things
what is a koan
proper definition
well try my best
okay so a coan is a phrase
it may be
a few words or it can be a few lines
long it may even be the longest two that
i know are about a page long each but
even in those ones we just kind of pull
out
a phrase here and a phrase there and
that's really the heart of the what the
cohen really is and these phrases
generally
they sort of don't make sense to our
normal
rational mind and it varies a bit i mean
like not knowing is most introvert it is
a by the way it's a totally bona fide
econ yeah absolutely come on it's with
this master called hogan
it's supposed to be the moment he had a
great awakening actually when he heard
another master tell him that and maybe
i'll come back to the story in a moment
that's almost a bit more
you could kind of wrap your head around
some idea of
not knowing his most intimate well
actually it's a little bit hard but you
could sort of think well actually tim
and henry were just a moment talking
about not knowing like going into
unknown land
as a sort of reclaiming part of the
south by recognizing that there's limits
to what i know of myself
so maybe there's some aspect to not
knowing that's connected with
personal growth of some kind
and i and actually i think tim your
comment about terror in
terror
that was great that was great because
actually we know that we're moving into
not knowing if we get a little bit
afraid fear is a hallmark of that
because it sort of is scary nearly
always
but so
you could
kind of maybe think about not knowing
his most intimate as
well not knowing will help me know
something about myself that i don't yet
know or something like that you could
sort of rationally approach it a little
bit but what about this sound of one
hand actually the the real sort of
really i don't know the the old
formulation of that hand of that cohen
is like this
you know the sound of two hands clapping
but what is the sound of one hand
in other words
you know what two hands clapping
sounds like
what does one hand sound like do you
know what the sound of one hand
is
that's kind of meaningless
really isn't it i mean some people tried
i've had people sort of snap their
fingers or something you know because
only one hand you know to make a noise
no no no no no it's not the basic thing
with coans is is the frame i think i've
got to give to understand
what they're sort of for
and why they're beautiful and why
they're not just
often in seemingly infuriating little
riddles that can't be un puzzled out
they're not just that they're actually
kissing the origin of them in almost i
think in every single case is something
that one of these deeply awakened
masters
said
or in some cases did
sometimes as somebody just does
something weird
and
most of the people doing or saying the
things in them
are
these zen practitioners
perhaps we should say chan practitioners
because zen was called chan
in china where it really comes from
and the japanese kind of took it on
about a thousand eight hundred years ago
and did a great job of sort of
conveying it and practicing with it and
passing it on so to speak but the
original practitioners
who
gave us a lot of the cards
most of them were chinese and they were
mostly in this period of chinese history
called the tang dynasty which was
600 to 900 approximately
and that's when zen is sort of said to
have had his first real flourishing
there were just a lot of people around
apparently at that time who were really
doing this practice and got kind of
really helped by it and
clarified in in certain key ways and the
key way
that coans
sort of
pass on
or allow us to maybe taste is
a dry way of putting it is we could say
non-dual experience that's sort of a bit
boring really to put it that way it's to
realize
through personal
experience
that
there are actually sort of other
dimensions to our experience
than we normally
experience
and what they are like
is
a kind of incredible overwhelming sense
that somehow
everything is one thing
that's one
common
[Music]
experience that cohen's are trying to
convey that all these separate things in
this world just like they seem to be
there's a table there's
there's a cup there's a tree outside
there's tim and i still on the east
coast tim somewhere yes
so timing east coast henry and new
mexico santa fe
and you know they're obviously
quite separate
but at the very same time there is
actually also
a level of our experience of our reality
where
nothing is separate
and
this isn't an idea
it's an actual experience
that quite a number of people
through the ages and today still
attest
to
being
something they've discovered and found
to be
real
that does not in any way impair
their functioning as a normal human
being
so it's not psychotic
and it's not delusional
it doesn't generally sort of take us off
into
dysfunction
quite the reverse it can
actually lead to
better mental health than we've had
before
and
it's kind of good for us apparently to
find this
and
koans
are
little invitations to
that
side of things
now
how they work is
actually should i should i give you a
chance to to say something and not just
rant away
is there anything
is there anything so far i know that
sort of doesn't make sense or anything
or am i going in a direction that's sort
of of interest do you think
it is of interest let me let me just
share a few things that may be of
interest to folks and i want you to
bookmark you were just about to get into
the way they work which is a hell of a
cliffhanger so i want you to remember
that that's okay that that's where you
are
i was i had a b in my bonnet about the
actual term koan and i had to look it up
because it's really bothering me because
the
characters are super strange
for the association that i have with the
meaning of koan and
i pulled it up on wikipedia and the
etymology
if you look at it the origin as you
mentioned of this expression is chinese
that's the
the two
or
depending on whether it's first or
fourth tone on the second syllable
and then koan are the same characters in
the
in japanese
but it literally could be translated as
public case
yeah like
i guess this would be
yeah fourth tone but if you'd like
first tone it would be like public
safety like public security
like you would see that on the people's
liberation jackets in beijing these huge
green jackets that in in some cases you
would see that so i was looking at this
and i'm just like what the hell does
this mean
because it's public
and then case or plan and i was like
where does that come from and so
it turns out that that is exactly
according to wikipedia
what it is it's referring to a public
record
and yeah the terminology came from the
the tang dynasty in china and thus the
koan serves as a metaphor i'm reading
directly from wikipedia for principles
of reality beyond the private opinion of
one person and a teacher may test the
student's ability to recognize and
understand that principle that is the
thing i really want to dig into
but okay but but this suffice to say
as stated here in wikipedia zenko and
collections are public records of the
notable sayings and actions of zen
masters
and disciples attempting to pass on
their teachings as so whether or not we
agree 100 of that i just had to get a
better understanding of why these
characters are used for this because it
is not obvious at all why they're
connected
so let's jump back to where you were
in terms of
how they work
and i just want to tease this for people
and that is and i i am going into the
abyss here because i don't know the
answer but the idea that a teacher may
test the student's ability to recognize
and understand that principle
seems
on its face just absurd right because
i it just does uh so i can't wait to
hear you tied together i will also say
that this experience of unity or
non-duality all as one etc
sounds really abstract and i suppose it
is
for those who have not experienced it
these are experiences that can be
captured
or reflected at least in
on some level functional mri
scans
with the administration of something
like psilocybin at a sufficiently high
dose so you see
and it's much more complex than this but
some down regulation of
or decreasing activity and what people
might consider the default mode network
this constellation of
neural components
thought to be associated with
among other things conception of ego
and self-referential thinking and so on
so even though it sounds very woo-woo
and how would anyone ever document this
this is a phenomenon that is
routinely documented
and assessed with questionnaires at
places like johns hopkins when they're
working with
psychedelic compounds not to say that
the experiences are identical but it's
just to point out that it's not
completely outside the reach of
experience and observation although zen
or chan buddhism had a head start of a
few thousand years
perhaps
no look all of that is fantastic i'm so
happy to hear you say that both parts
because you know my own little sort of
hobby horse these days kind of thing is
that i'm so happy about the psychedelic
research
because it's giving us
new tools
for once again
resuming the study of meditation at
deeper levels yeah because a lot of the
study of meditators brains over the last
30 years or whatever it's been has been
about mindfulness it's been about yeah
quieting the default mode network and
just getting into maybe more
compassionate states of mind or just
more equanimous states of mind but it
hasn't really tapped into
the capacity or it's minimally tapped
into the capacity of meditation to yield
to bring us to these non-dual states
which are
really the heart of the matter and so
now the psychedelic research is opening
that up again and it's creating new ways
of measuring
longevity of change in people who've
been through experiences like this you
know which was so hard to do before
because you couldn't
you can't really get somebody in in an
mri and say have kensho you know kensho
being the zen name for you know
awakening to the principle which is
non-dual so
psychedelic research is really helping
with that and it's actually it's funny
that
zen you know had a real popularity in
the west back in the 50s 60s 70s 80s
even still
in the kind of heyday and then aftermath
of psychedelic culture people recognized
wow zen seems to know about what i
tasted on that last acid trip it seems
to have some congruence with that and
maybe
meditation is a way to sort of get there
in a more stable way kind of thing and
without having to take a substance and
maybe that's the case you know really so
i think now
zen got a little bit sort of i mean it
was almost kind of mainstream really for
a while yeah uh you had like jd salinger
allen ginsberg jack kerouac
right i mean
and uh i mean not not to mention you
know alan watts and
so on right so it was in the it was in
the zeitgeist for sure
and i think maybe it's due for a
reappraisal at the moment and and maybe
co-ants can be a part of this i'm so
convinced because because
now okay public case that's exactly
right now one interpretation that i've
heard of what the public the term public
case means
is that actually it was taken from
tang dynasty
legal processes so essentially a public
case was a public record
of some point of legislation or some
what we would call a legal precedent
today case record of a public law court
at least according to wikipedia
right okay great so i'm not off chapter
so basically meaning that
you could point to
actually was a master called echo who
was an amazing master in the
late 7th early 8th century if i remember
right who said the single hand doesn't
sound
without reason that was what he said the
single hand sounds you know so that's a
little obscure of course it's very
obscure but
actually he was trying to express
his experience of quote-unquote
awakening in other words he's trying to
use language
to convey
what is basically a non-linguistic
experience
and even an experience that we don't
really have language for
but it's a very vivid and real
experience
in which the sense of self has been
swallowed up by everything kind of thing
and so what we feel we are is everything
and koans are
records of that in a sense they like
it's a great practitioner expressing
through words
what he or she
has realized
therefore
the idea is
the
ordinary way of constructing reality
where i am a self in this body and
everything else is outside of me
that way of constructing reality won't
understand the command can't get at what
the cone is getting at
the coan is a little
drill bit that's drilling into the wall
of my house of self so to speak it's
trying to actually puncture
the membrane of my sense of self
switching metaphors you know it's trying
to i sometimes have talked to them of
like they're like uh
they're like little explosives we take
them into the psyche by sitting with
them
you kind of do best with them if you
have a meditation practice
you let them sort of somehow simmer away
inside you
and they will
possibly
do something to deep assumptions that i
have and one of those deep assumptions
is that i'm me in my body in my mind and
i'm not what's outside
of me and that's
that's a deep assumption and the koan
can kind of blow a hole in it in the
assumption and
and suddenly i discover that's not true
or part is it's true but it's not the
whole truth there's another reality that
is real i mean it is a dimension of our
reality where there isn't separation
between things there isn't distance
between things somehow there's one
fabric one sort of tissue
that's what they mean by the way in when
you're quoting the word principle that's
what it means it means a single
tissue a single fabric that
is what everything's made of henry may i
jump in here for one second please
please please
no no no because i have a tendency of
saying no no no and what i really mean
is yes yes yes i'm psycho analyst or
therapist can really uh do a deep dive
on that i'm sure but
returning to
the
point i wanted to make there are no
doubt going to be people listening who
are like what the [ __ ] are these people
talking about so what i'd love to do
because they might assume you have to do
a lot of drugs or like lock yourself in
a room in a robe until you basically go
crazy for any of this to make sense
let me ask some super specific questions
and if you wouldn't mind
i think this would be a way because this
this is the itch that i want to scratch
for myself also
and it's related to
to the extent that one exists the system
around or that includes colons so one of
the questions that kevin wanted me to
ask you
is how many koans are there and how many
have you passed
so give me the short
answer to that and then we can we can go
from there because yeah i think it
people will be like what okay and it
might it might pull people in so
how many cons are there that you're
aware of and how many have you passed
okay i'm aware that i've read that there
are 1700 that are kind of classically
recognized koans
nearly all from that tang dynasty period
and a few from
way earlier actually a few have come out
of the indian phase of buddhism you know
way back
in the fourth uh centuries bce
so
apparently 1700 but in practice what
happens is there are these different
sort of schools of zen
that will use certain collections so no
not to my knowledge no school uses 1700
co-ads no training involves that many in
the school that i'm part of called [ __ ]
zen
we use something like i believe it's
around
420 is what i've heard fairly recently
actually from one of our one of my
colleagues had sort of counted it up and
they're in five collections of cards so
these coins got collected
mostly in tsung dynasty china that's
around
1100 1200
and these sort of classic collections
were compiled and there are several of
them there are maybe three really major
collections
the earliest was put together in 1028
it's called the blue cliff record
and that has a hundred coans in it
and then there's another one called the
book of equanimity there's also got 100
and there's another one called the
gateless gate that has 48
and actually there's quite a bit of
overlap among those volumes and then
there's another volume that we use and
there's a preliminary kind of volume of
just the sort of hot potch of coans that
one of our teachers in the lineage put
together
called the miscellaneous cohens because
they are just miscellaneous and so what
we do okay so this is how it works is
that if somebody's really kind of
got a steady meditation practice and
they have found ways to get to the point
where they kind of like meditating henry
hold your hold your thought
but if i had to answer kevin's question
is there maybe it's a bad question i
don't know because i don't know what i'm
talking about but how many of those
1700 or 420 have you passed because i
think that's a concept that is going to
be interesting to people
okay so i can modestly and humbly say
that i have been passed on
all of the ones that we do the 420
at least
two at the minimum times in some cases
multiple times the reason i say multiple
times because i first went through them
all with one teacher and then actually
my teacher john
gainer roshi in the uk
and then i moved to new mexico and
picked up with my teacher joan rick
roshi and sort of carried on with her
and so between those two teachers i did
one go through them all
then
i did another go through all of them
with my teacher reuben habito roshi
who's a professor of comparative
religion at smu in dallas a fantastic
guy they're all fantastic fantastic
people by the way
and
also i've done
many with my current teacher yamada
roshi
and i've also
also done
i mean i've done a lot of them
at least three times and i probably
i'd say
hazard that i've done
just about all of them
three times
but
definitively probably
three and i don't know three quarters of
them two and three quarters of them you
know okay three times you know i thought
that i would have a set a finite list of
questions but now i just have more
questions about questions of all things
so
if i may just dance with me here a
little bit so there are
there there are these many cons but
there is
four practical purposes subsets that are
practiced by different schools
you are
in the sambal
i guess [ __ ] kyodan right [ __ ] school
the three treasures is that right
something like that yeah that's right
yeah and
you have been passed
and we haven't yet explained what that
is on these various
koans some of them two or three times
now in my head i'm thinking like once
you have an answer don't you just kind
of have the answer what does it mean to
be past two or three times
and then
i'm gonna give you another question from
kevin and then i'm gonna let you run
wild okay and that is what are the
checking questions what are the checking
questions because when i first had these
sent to me from kevin
i thought to myself well this is
interesting because in my head i'm
imagining this koan
using your earlier description as
this sort of trojan horse software that
puts a little snippet of code in your
head
and
your computer can't run the program
so you basically just like beach ball
your way into giving up on rationality
and then somehow poof you have this
kensho
unity experience because you break your
computer
and
whether that happened or not is kind of
your word against somebody else's word
right
so the idea that there there is there
are checking questions and passing i'm
like okay
i want to know all about that so okay
with that please go crazy
yeah well that it all ties into what you
just said it's your word against
somebody else's as to whether you've had
ketchup that's the point really it's not
it's not
it's really not and the reason it isn't
is that
if somebody's had kensho
oh my god the way they
experienced the co-owner
will have changed utterly
and the way they are if they meet with a
teacher
if they do i mean we've got to bear in
mind that this is not the only way of
working with currents actually there's
nothing wrong with somebody just
deciding they want to sit with a cohen
fine but i've got a friend who doesn't
even sit with him he likes reading them
fine there's no ban on that you know
it's that's totally up to you but this
system
of training
you can actually i mean like with on sam
harris's app for example we've got these
cohen meditations and you just sit with
them and it's a bit like
for example in the zendo when we're open
or even when we're i mean in live but
when we're on on zoom people come and
they just you know they hear a talk on a
command they get to sort of
bask in the
weird waters of a cohen for a while
while the teacher's giving a
disquisition on the cohen it may be
opaque and yet there may be most when
suddenly they feel some weird movement
inside a stirring of something within
and some weird little
pool of limpid clarity opens they know
what the hell is this but it's beautiful
olympic clarity that's my third podcast
poorly socialized and then to offset the
damage from that podcast i have
limpid clarity please continue so there
are different ways of working with them
but this way whereby
you
have sort of decided to engage a teacher
with them
if you have this kenjo experience i mean
in a way
the very point of the cohen is it's a
it's a meeting place where
two people two practitioners one more
experience than the other can actually
meet through the cohen
in
the very reality
they've awakened to i mean to me
that's the most precious and amazing
thing about it is that
far from
this sort of
awakening thing you know this awakening
and non-dual being just a
personal experience of course it is that
but actually through cohen's you can
meet in it you meet in the boundless
wonder
of this
other dimension of our experience i
think i said last time we were talking
and i talked about in my book i had
a couple of of these what i felt to be
very powerful experiences of non-duality
and they were slightly different each
one
prior to connecting with a teacher i'd
been trying to find a teacher actually
but sort of wasn't ready but then
eventually when i did connect with the
first teacher that i really engaged with
john
in the uk and john gainer i got my first
comment from him which was
this often it's the first coin which is
it's so inscrutable i mean it's just
sort of damnable i mean i i'm
embarrassed to even say it but it's this
cohen that a lot of people start with
which is moo mu mu that's it that's the
whole thing that's it
i mean it has it has a little background
story among ask joshu this great master
jiaozhou joshu and sino japanese does a
dog have buddha nature buddha nature
meaning this awakened nature or
principle as it as it was referred to
earlier does a dog even a dog have that
he asks
and joshua answers
mu
which ostensibly means not
it does mean not literally but
it's sort of a principle of buddha
nature that it's everything
so
how could a dog not have it sort of
thing and yet joshua says moo so we
don't worry about that we just sit with
mu
we just sit with mu it's we could almost
take it like when joshua says moo he's
sort of just dismissing the whole
question
i'm not going to deal with that
something like that but he's also
presenting
that very reality in that little word
moo because actually that very reality
is showing up all the time right here
right now it's always present this
so-called principle you know it's always
present
it's always here it's just we're not
conditioned to know it clearly what you
mean by that is the principle of not or
the principle of emptiness is that what
you mean is that what you're referring
to yes it is yes basically the principle
of what i was calling non-duality which
also happens to be empty the principle
of total oneness which is also empty
that's always here so when joshua says
mu he's
expressing that in his way
mu just then he's expressing it
and so
a student assists with this question mu
if and when
they have a
an opening you know with this with
sitting with mu
and to be clear that is not
done by thinking about it no it's not
you're not reflecting and ruminating
you're just kind of sitting there with
this software this code that's been
installed
and yes
okay all right yeah you're just you're
usually just sort of repeating it softly
you sort of add it to your breath
meditation usually
just softly
voicing this sound mu
with each breath and you just sort of
patiently do it the more patiently you
do it
the better because you'll be more
comfortable and
it starts to just sort of
sort of in a way take over your sitting
in a very nice gentle kind of way kind
of thing it's a little bit like a mantra
you know it's a little bit like that but
anyway so it's a little unlike other
coins in that regard because you use it
that way let's say something happens
when you go to see the teacher
you both sort of light up in this other
dimension kind of thing it's i know i'm
sorry i'm not expressing it very well
you meet
in a way
that
i mean i certainly
coming back to when i was working with
my teacher john when i went in to see
him
after i'd had some experience with mu
i don't know if there's any interest but
i could tell you what that was like
sure anybody wants yeah please and then
i'm not gonna let go i'm like a dog with
a bone on this checking questions thing
i'm not going to let that go but please
yes i would love to hear about the
experience
and i'm truly going to the checking
questions truly this is
it's a long journey together a long and
winding road two checking questions so
this is also just to exemplify how much
this can happen in the midst of ordinary
life i was
busy as a writer and as a poet i was
doing lots of readings i was working on
my next book i just sold a book and
working out the contract with my agent
all of that stuff going on you know busy
and
kind of productive and i've got a
fellowship in poetry at oxford brooks
university at the time and one day and
i've been sitting with moo and often
when i'm riding my bike to the office
and in the college you know i'm using
moo and as i'm riding along just comes
to mind
and instead of what is this thing you
know just doing it and then one day i'm
home i've just made dinner and our two
boys are young and they're watching a
movie and i'm bringing a plate of food
upstairs
for claire my wife is
the boys have already eaten they're
watching who framed roger rabbit that
great movie you know on the video with
bob hoskins and i bring in
claire's plate of food
and i think i'm still holding mine
and i'm watching this scene on the movie
where
roger rabbit goes whirring round around
a kitchen while his rear end is on fire
i don't know if you've seen it oh yeah
i've seen it more times than i should
probably admit
it's been it's been a while but yes i've
seen it
it's a fantastic film i thought at least
that's the last time i saw it
20 years ago whatever that was and
i was watching that scene and it just
suddenly seemed just so funny and then
all of a sudden this
crazy sort of like a cyclone energy sort
of whips up through my body and blam
it's really like
i sort of black out
i'm on my feet
and everything's disappeared
everything's just gone it's just a
empty
vast empty space that's so beautiful
and nothing
there and then i sort of come back i
realize i'm sort of standing in this
room holding a plate which somehow i
haven't dropped and
it's like the house is still here but
it's sort of not really made of anything
it's totally
discombobulating and marvelous and i'm
just trembling with
some sort of overwhelming gratitude and
love and it's like somehow this empty
space that everything's in is just so
overwhelmingly beautiful and it's just
like a huge love
and i'm overwhelmed i can't believe
how fortunate it is to be a human being
you know it's like
it's just
indescribable so and this is all coming
out of this little word moo i've been
sitting assiduously with mu and at the
time i didn't even realize it had
anything to do with moo you know it's
just like this mind-blowing experience
so i go downstairs i sort of you know i
think i better sit and light a stick of
incense and maybe i'll just kind of calm
down and i don't it's i'm
supremely happy it's it's
i'm overwhelmed with happiness tears are
flowing down my cheeks and
it's just so beautiful and so then you
know two weeks later or something i get
to
visit with john a teacher and i tell him
this thing
and he says something like ah
so
mu has paid you a visit or something
like that and i thought what's he
talking about
how could
mu
have anything to do with
that
but suddenly
the penny drops
and i realized oh my god
this is what a cohen is for it's for
precipitating
it's for sharing
this
[ __ ] reality you know excuse my greek
it's
it's
it's it's a cohen
isn't an annoying boring little
pointless thing it's got an incredible
purpose which is sharing this sort of
deepest reality of our existence
and
how can it do it i mean
i still don't really understand how it
can do it i can sort of
piece it together a little bit the
so yeah joshua knew this world
incredibly well he was he was accustomed
to it it becomes second nature to him he
was at ease in it and he knew that you
know this sort of normal way things are
and this mind-blowing way things also
are are not in the end separate that's
the point of the training ongoing in
cohen's is to go beyond this
either life is this mind-blowing
boundless
oneness emptiness thing or it's my
ordinary life
but the point of training
damn am i getting am i going ahead let
me can i just finish that thought
finish the thought yes please wow god
kevin i i i hope this isn't too much for
everybody
no it's not and i also like being kevin
so please continue
god i can tell him
my mind is blown i'm sorry i think we've
just got a hold of you right now you've
got to be careful
oh my god yeah so that is why we sit
with cards is because they can open up
they can open us up to this
boundless
reality but on going beyond a first
experience
they train us
more and more in realizing that our
ordinary life and that mind-blowing
reality they're not separate and that
that's a very hard thing to understand
but that's why so many comments are
about things
so no okay i want to talk about cohens
are about things and comments love the
world
so much and they love us they want us to
share in it and basically of course they
don't really but the masters the
practitioners who created the cards
deeply compassionate and they wanted
to share
somehow what they had realized
and
it's pretty amazing so checking
questions
so when i
yeah okay okay he's gonna be he's on it
he's on the center
[Laughter]
oh my god he this is gonna be a bit of a
letdown probably when an anti-climactic
finally i'll be the judge of that
okay
well the checking questions were what
john started to ask me about
moo
that enabled
him
and me
to meet more thoroughly
and to know more deeply
basically what
experience had just happened in this
student me
they're questions like actually i don't
know how much of this i could sort of
reveal but that yeah i think i can you
know they're things like well show me
moo what is moo how old is mu how tall
is moo how would you show me to a baby
they're weird questions like that but
after that experience they're easy
they're easy and
they're so they're kind of
yeah this is a system for
sharing
what we mean by awakening
right as sort of a
being able to
as in the sort of legal precedent sort
of to
to kind of meet in the same place so to
speak
all right i have so many follow-ups so i
want to preface all of the follow-ups by
saying
i am
genuinely fascinated by all of this
simultaneously i have to act as a
stand-in for the audience listening so
you can understand i have to both be
enthusiastic i don't have to but i am
enthusiastic and i have to present
or i should ask questions on behalf of
the audience who might be thinking to
themselves at least a handful of them
what the hell is going on
yes so
it's so uh-huh so
this is great this is great we're
getting i like it we're rolling in the
butt here it's good so the first
question that hopped to mind for me
is
related to
sure an observation that many people had
or a thought that occurred to them which
is if you were to go to a psychiatrist
and describe your experience with your
dinner plate
there is a very good chance they would
consider that a psychotic break or label
it a delusion of grandeur and prescribe
medication for you that would be one
very likely psychiatric
treatment response right
and
and what i'm curious to know is
or just to get your opinion on and this
is by
by no means meant to imply that people
who have
destabilizing experiences shouldn't seek
professional help i think they should
but
do you think that these types of
experiences can show in the
benefit or detriment of an experience
like that is dependent on the container
and
framework that you have within which to
try to metabolize that
and
building on top of that and i've
wondered this quite a bit because with
psychedelic experiences you come to have
over time i think tremendous
empathy for people who appear to be
suffering from mental illness say
homeless people who seem disconnected
from reality
in your opinion right this is not
medical advice it's just curiosity
do you think that
some subset of people we view as
completely mentally detached are just
people who had experiences of ken show
perhaps identical to what you
experienced but have no means for trying
to make any sense of it and therefore
become lost at sea
i think it's quite
possible that that's the case tragically
i do quite a number of people that you
know have reached out to me
report
having had something like this
earlier in life i can think of several
people who did as teenagers
and had no idea they somehow in the
depths of the experience they felt this
was a kind of vastly benevolent
thing to perceive to undergo to
experience
and then afterwards
got terribly scared
and didn't know what was going on
what had just happened to them were they
going crazy and
in some cases
got unhappy got depressed
anxious
for some years
and i think that it could be that
in some cases it could it could be
graver than that and if somebody
is already
perhaps traumatized anyway as so many
are
it might initially be yeah a very
benevolent thing
but then there's no container there's no
understanding they're completely alone
with it and it could be really scary
and it could become
another traumatizing factor i think that
happens and it's it's very sad and i
feel part of what i want to do is get
the word out widely that this is a
feature of human nature it is something
we we're built with the capacity to have
these kinds of experiences and they're
they are
you know vastly benevolent in the end
and they may also be really pretty
[ __ ] weird at the beginning and so i
want people to know
you know that this is a feature of human
nature and therefore there are places
you can reach out people you can reach
out to and you don't have to be doing
collins for this by the way the koan
method
i think is a beautiful thing because
it makes it more accessible to more of
us it's not a freak thing if somebody
has that kind of experience with the
kind it's still
by no means
totally predictable or reliable or
something but it's not a freak thing and
it also the koan training subsequently
is exactly a sort of way of grounding it
integrating it getting more familiar
with it probably deepening it clarifying
further and learning how to just
effortlessly
live from it in your normal life
and not feel you've got to do you know
you've got to
quit everything and go and live on a
mountaintop or something you don't have
to you know the mountaintops right here
anyway kind of thing so the more that
people are aware of this and the more it
becomes
part of the
conversation the public discourse the
better and you know so far in the world
of meditation a lot of the public
discourse around meditation most of it
has been about the
nervous system calming benefits of
mindfulness absolutely right right on
it's great that that's happening and
then you've got
people like sam sam harris who are
bringing this experience of waking up
waking out of
the
dualistic separate sense of self into a
much more inclusive kind of awareness
that is
deeply beneficial to experience
in principle because it shows our
infinite connectedness and if trauma is
about ultimate separation and isolation
you know the poor child with the
overwhelming emotions totally alone
can show if we call it that using
japanese terminology is exactly the
opposite it's about infinite
connectedness
and that is a is the most
wonderful thing to discover it's it
cannot but
flood us with love
at least briefly and if we're then
really
freaked out
i want people to know that
it's okay you haven't gone mad you've in
fact discovered something
really beautiful and real about your
human nature and there is follow-up
there are ways of gradually integrating
it and hallelujah that you've seen this
it's amazing and
okay i'll pause there
uh
thank you for the pause i would imagine
though that this puts you in sometimes a
very tricky position where you have an
audience now you're
on a larger platform you're on podcasts
like this and
people must reach out to you
some percentage of which
describe an experience that they have
interpreted
as kensho and for people who are
interested
kensho is actually written in a really
cool way it's ken show which is like
seeing nature or essence and it's a cool
combination of characters which does
make a lot of sense
unlike the my original exposure to koan
and
i would suspect that you have some
subset of people who come to you who
really should have psychiatric treatment
just like out of the
out of the ether right kind of over the
transom from the public
and i would expect that puts you in a
tricky situation because
having spent time
around people who are having
breakdowns and maybe not breakthroughs
sometimes one and the same but not
always yeah
is that something that has been
challenging for you when someone who is
perhaps going through a manic episode or
having some type of
potentially destructive experience that
is quite isolating for them right it's
kind of separating
perhaps reaches out to you to validate
it as can show and therefore
something that does not require
intervention
so far it's been comparatively rare
and i think the reason is that um that's
good
yeah i know i mean i can think of one
clear time it did actually there's
somebody who wanted to come on a retreat
and
we were we meaning myself and the little
team at the zendo was a little bit wary
because of some of the things she said
and we asked about her psychiatric
background and
there was some things she told us and
then she came and it was clear that you
know she really was in much worse shape
than she'd let on and one guy who was
part of the zender team then who was a
therapist
he sort of spent some time with her and
then actually he decided
that she really needed to be
taken to the psych ward for an
evaluation
so
that was what we did there and she was
compliant with that but usually people
know that there's kind of
whatever exactly role i'm in is
i teach meditation and so you kind of
got to be into meditation
really you know that's like not you know
not everybody is and it's you know it's
quite i i don't know if i'd say it's
demanding but it's the main method here
i don't teach just
hey let's talk about comments no i teach
meditating and and one of the ways
i teach meditation is meditation with
cohen's it's not the only way but for
those that are inclined we can do that
but also like i said there's there's a
large number of people i think getting
interested in cohen's you don't really
feel the need to engage with the teacher
and that's okay they find their
meditation is deeper if they've got a
cohan that they're touching
their
repeating or thinking of a little bit
while they meditate it's just sort of
enriches the meditation some people have
reported to me just having really deep
sits peaceful
lovely deep joyful peaceful sits when
they bring a cohen in there's no idea
really what what the cohen's kind of
saying what it's about or what he did
not know interesting how it might lead
to kensho they're just they just sort of
find the phrase is somehow absorbing
and relaxing perhaps and casts a kind of
little bit of a spell
over their meditation and they find this
really deep
and that's lovely no problem there and i
think this kensho businesses and the
real deep comment trainings is not for
everybody yeah
yeah true of a lot of things
right so let me follow up with a couple
of
exploratory points i'm gonna get into
some of the the weirder stuff in a
minute but let's start with the
assumption
that
the experience as you described it
is
absolutely true this is where i want to
start just as a basis for the the
question i'm going to ask you in other
words
that
this experience of ken show is
not an everyday by all people thing but
it is not a freak thing another way to
put it would be it's reasonably common
it's been reasonably common for hundreds
or thousands of years there are shared
characteristics
and it kind of takes one to no one if
that makes any sense right like one
obi-wan can kind of look at another
obi-wan
in training and
the the force is strong with this one
you have passed you have passed this
so
after asking the checking questions
right i mean i'm obviously joking around
a little bit but let's just
take it
as true that that
exists as an experience as a phenomenon
as a training
how does someone
who is brand new to zen
separate someone who is legitimate as a
teacher from a charlatan because i have
been
exposed and overexposed to the
let's just call it the you know
so-called self-development fields the
personal development fields to
the medical fields to the medical and
quotation marks fields
for decades and
all of them
are rife with
charlatans for people who claim to have
a set of expertise
and skills that they do not or people
who make promises they cannot deliver
and i have to imagine on some level
there are people running around claiming
to be
masters or experts in zen who aren't
how can one who hasn't had these
experiences
assess who is real and who is not
if i just describe a little bit how it
works in [ __ ] zed and that would be a
starting point great let's do it okay in
[ __ ] zen
somebody called it a sort of equal
hierarchy kind of thing everyone is
equal but there are grades of
responsibility so there's an assistant
teacher there's an assistant zen an
assistant teacher can do usually they
work with a zen teacher
as an assistant to them and they can do
a certain amount of things
as the teacher wants a zen teacher can
do everything they can meaning they can
give talks they can use the cohens they
can
meet with students and
and they can sort of run a zendo
completely you know then there's
so-called associate
masters and this is all within [ __ ] zen
i'm just giving you sort of a framework
so you can get some sense of how it
works and these associate masters can
appoint a personal teacher they can't
appoint a [ __ ] zen teacher and then
there are so called sort of they're
called authentic masters or just masters
and they can appoint
[ __ ] zen teachers so they can sort of
appoint people in the name of the
lineage and there aren't many of them
and they tend to do it sort of
collaboratively if they're
going to appoint people so in other
words
there's quite a
i don't know if it's elaborate but
there's a certain sort of careful system
for who gets what level of
responsibility
as a teacher now
i feel
that i'm happy that it's like that
because
it means that
at every step of the way there's some
accountability it's not just
i tell everybody
i have this awakening experience i'm an
awakened master i want to be a teacher
now in fact in samba zen there's almost
a bit of a view that if somebody wants
to be a teacher they may not be ready
yet
if they're gonna get something out of
being a teacher
i mean it's hard to be perfect about
this to be honest but
if somebody is needing
the affirmation of being a teacher
you know and after all it's kind of a
whoa you're a spiritual teacher that's
pretty exalted right if somebody's
needing that kind of affirmation
they're probably not ready to do it and
we just wait
and every year all the teachers of all
levels and all the senior students who
their teachers have thought this person
might be ready to start training to be a
teacher they all gather we all gather
for a week-long retreat and
workshop and we do a lot with the coans
and people have to give talks in front
of the others it's pretty terrifying
because i mean one of the most
frightening things
more frightening than being on the tim
ferriss podcast actually
which by the way i'm finding very
enjoyable
it's not as frightening as i thought
terror incognita
exactly
oh my god but you know one of the most
frightening things i've done really was
have to give i've done it twice now give
a talk to you know 80 90
zen teachers oh my god all my seniors
and anyway in other words it's totally
not down to me to say i'm a teacher
in fact it's rather carefully titrated
over the years you get more and more
responsibility as you're ready for it if
you see what i mean so okay so that's
how we do it now
those quote-unquote masters they get
this
formal
old-style zen
authorization called dharma transmission
which is you know it's very moving to
get that because it you know it really
means your your the whole body is really
trusting you
and why would they do that but they've
decided they do and so you just accept
it and you hope you'll do your best and
it's it's a very moving thing what do
you mean by the whole body if i heard
you correctly
i guess i mean like the whole
organization of [ __ ] zen now is the
dharma transmission so i've heard
transmission used in yogic practices in
very specific ways is that a promotion
effectively or is it a transmission that
that sounds really crass i know but
in other words is it like a title or if
that's the right way to pronounce that
title or i don't you get the idea
involving titles honor that is bestowed
upon you
and it's it's sort of a formal
recognition or is there an actual
transmission from one person to another
does that make sense it totally does
it's kind of got at least two meanings
one would be
yeah
somebody really gets it
they really get the dharma they really
get
what this is all about and
they do it in conjunction with their
teacher
and that is a kind of dharma
transmission
in a sense but it's not really that
there's anything transmitted because
you're realizing that it's all one
so nothing can be transmitted it's like
you're truly discovering
that we're all
one
one thing it's no distance no space no
time no separation that all is clear and
it's clear here and now it's clear in
the company of a teacher of another
and maybe in some sense the teachers
helped that become clear so is the moral
of
your description
or the lesson the take home lesson from
your description of how [ __ ] kyodan
handles
structure of the organization
responsibilities
in essence to say beware of rogue
zen masters running around
that is to say like that you should look
for
a
recognized
organization with some type of
self-governance and
so on
as a starting point
i just think if you do find
somebody who's in that kind of realm
it's probably safer because for one
thing
they will have been fairly closely
vetted over quite a number of years
by somebody else now who that other
person was and how reliable they were
who knows but at least they've then
further been sort of vetted by a number
of people by a sort of body of people
and
you know that means that you feel and of
course we develop relationships with our
peers and i don't want to let them down
by misbehaving for example you know i
feel that i have a real deep
responsibility obviously to people who
want to study with me what an honor that
anybody would and also to my my buddies
my friends my colleagues who are other
zen teachers and to my own teachers i
don't want to let people down and
so there's a sense of
the way it's organized in samsung would
bring quite a few breaks
on would exert quite a bit of resistance
on anybody who wanted to go rogue kind
of thing they've got some endorsement i
think it's a bit safer they've got an
organization that has a code of ethics
and i'm not saying at all that sanders
is the only one like that there's
there's many other zen organizations and
non-zen organizations that have this
kind of
some sort of levels of responsibility
that are bestowed or whatever on their
teachers so it's not the teacher just
setting themselves up and that have
accountability to one another and to of
course to students and actually i think
there are many quite
well organized spiritual sort of
institutions organizations in the west
today which is just great and vino
vipassana has a number of really big
really well organized
outfits and that's fantastic tibetan
buddhism does i think as well and
zen certainly does
and so
the rogue teacher thing
i mean it's always a hazard isn't it i
don't think there's any
total foolproof
way but i would think that
things to watch out for would be
does somebody seem to have
some kind of accountability to a wider
organization
do they have fellow teachers that
they're in contact with
sort of accountability i think so this
is also a thing with the cohens you see
they're trying
to set up a system
whereby
there can be some
shared sort of agreement
about what this awakening experience is
and the koans themselves they are sort
of checking points
not knowing is most intimate
how might a student and teacher handle
that if they meet with that cohan and
they are also
a way of
checking that we're sort of on the same
page
so let's talk about that page and this
is a good segue to strangeville so let's
do that because i'm always eager to take
uh my you know my occasional jaunt into
strange fiddle
and
i want to preface this exploration by
saying
that
i pay a lot of attention to
two ends of a spectrum
when it comes to
i know people will dispute this word
they're not going to like it because
they'll say the plural of anecdote does
not equal data
but when i'm considering the potential
veracity of something on one end you
have randomized controlled
trials fantastic i'm highly supportive
and engaged with a lot of
studies and clinical trials and so on
this is really really important very
very
powerful
framework
that scientific method as implemented in
rcts for asking questions of nature
testing hypotheses and getting answers
back fantastic
but there are limited
researchers limited funding for studies
not everything is going to be studied so
we have to make decisions or
interpret reality
by and large in the absence of rcts so
on the other end of the spectrum you
have direct experience
so if i trust
the
fidelity of my own senses
what have i experienced and
what i've experienced multiple times
over and over again
what patterns have i identified i pay a
lot of attention to those things and
testing and you know for our body
actually my second book is a good
example of this there are many things in
that book that were
highly controversial seemingly highly
speculative but tested and measured
multiple times across multiple people
and
many of those particular items now have
more and more widely accepted scientific
support so
it can start off with an n of one is
what i'm saying but
i want to dig into this checking
question business
and i will offer something on my side
just so i it doesn't seem like an
inquisition so
on my side i will say something that i
have
observed and experienced and also
compared
with
the experiences of
dozens at least of other people at this
point
is the
apparent phenomenon of shared visions on
certain types of
psychedelics and what that means is
people are seeing
hearing
or feeling the same thing simultaneously
and by any kind of secular scientific
stretch of the imagination or assessment
these are hallucinations but
even if they are hallucinations
it's interesting to me that consistently
shared visions
let's just use visions for the time
being
seem to be a common reported
characteristic of certain psychedelics
like ayahuasca going back hundreds of
years these are in fact so consistent
that they are relied upon
in certain implementations and usages of
ayahuasca and south america
okay putting aside whether that is true
or not it is widely reported and
experientially it appears to be a real
phenomenon that's what i would say can i
prove it no i can't prove it just like
you can't stick me in a or anyone for
that matter you into an mri machine and
be like okay three two one and ken
kensho right it just doesn't doesn't
seem to work that way and i recognize
all the criticisms that could be it's
kind of levied against
what i'm describing so i'm well aware of
it and moving on
when you talk about
this experience of ken show
and
then having the checking questions
how tall is mu how would you introduce
a baby to mood these types of questions
i'm probably not phrasing them
exactly correctly
that sounds super bizarre right i mean
to anyone listening who's never
experienced something like this it
sounds super strange even to me where i
like i spent a lot of time in some
pretty unusual spaces and
it still sounds pretty strange
so
what do you think is happening there
because to me
there have been surveys i guess you
could look at them as observational
studies but surveys performed by
different universities looking at
so-called entity encounters with
compounds like nndmt
so when i hear you talk about these
questions like how tall is mu it sounds
like we're describing
an entity or something that exists
independently of the
observer or the experiencer in this case
you how would you
explain what the hell is going on or
describe the describe this further okay
first of all let me just uh how do i put
this so
i mean i love what you're saying about
the shared visions i get that actually i
i really yeah it's fantastic to hear
now with say this sort of ken show thing
is
it's
actually
the
questions are doing there's got a dual
function
one
is
we will be able to answer these
questions if we've had kensho and
especially if we've had it fairly
recently so it's still kind of alive and
vivid say within a few months or even
weeks or days or even hours if it
happens on a retreat
so
they are number one the way we respond
to them will
confirm
that
we've really experienced this thing
secondly
they will
somehow
help us
explore it even more deeply
now
that actually doesn't mean that it's an
entity other than us that we've
experienced now it's more like
my experience has shifted in a certain
way which is really opened up a
different way of experiencing
altogether
and
these probing questions
allow me to
inhabit
this new way of experiencing
more
and they allow me or they help me
to realize
that this new way of experiencing is
actually not contradictory to
my ordinary way of experiencing
in other words
i can start to see
that this
mind-blowing sort of other dimension
for one of better phrasing
is in fact
present
in
my everyday experience
that's what it's really trying to do is
to help me
to sort of
less
know it as this other weirdness
mind-blowing and lovely though maybe
it's other
and to sort of actually
wow
i'm living this all the time and i
didn't realize and it's not actually
foreign and other
and
that gives hope really that there is a
way
of integrating it there's a way of
having it be
present
in a very positive way
in our ordinary life that's
non-problematic quite the reverse and i
mean i'm gonna point to
my master yamada roshi who is an
extremely successful businessman he was
head of mitsubishi's securities with
something like 30 000 employees you know
under him and and could do all that
while practicing zen very seriously and
earnestly and deeply while having
mind-blowing experiences or whatever
while doing a lot of current training
none of it
interfered with his work life in fact he
thinks it he said he he wasn't he was
he's a reasonably good student he felt
but not the best and
he thinks the reason he had a
very good career
is his zen
it gave him
more balance more clarity more empathy
more
compassion and more
openness to seeing things from other
people's points of view
and
yeah a sort of you know wisdom perhaps
in how to approach things may i hop in
for a second henry yeah please yeah okay
all right so
i absolutely agree that
zen practice are many practices that
might be thought
to be antithetical or somehow
compromising to your
normal waking reality let's just say and
so i i certainly don't think zen
practice is
incompatible right it seems highly
compatible and if if kevin's
experience limited as it may be is any
indication that's certainly true right
it's it's been nothing but an enhancer
for him and i want to come back just for
a second again not to beat a dead horse
but
to
these
checking questions with respect to mu
and to
also clarify for people listening that
when i asked about the entity
sort of the relating to these questions
and to mu
and whether or not there was the
perception of independent entity it's
not so much that i'm saying
there is an independent entity because
that's not the part that i find
interesting if we're just looking at the
perceptual experience of multiple people
what i find so
bizarre and tantalizing at the same time
is that
whether or not these things are
happening for the reasons
we believe them to be happening whether
or not the explanations are accurate
yeah
if we take it
as true for now that
you and many other people are having
consistent enough experiences in this
non-dual state in this experience that
is labeled kensho with within [ __ ]
kyodan right
that you can
consistently answer
similarly answer the questions how tall
is mu how would you introduce mutual
baby and so on
yes is uh
[ __ ] weird right and yeah
and and that's not to say it's untrue i
want to be super clear here
but i want to hear like if if you had
three drinks and we were just
at a steakhouse in uh in london and i
was like henry
what the [ __ ] is going on here what do
you think is happening here like how is
it that multiple people could answer
these questions with similar or the same
answers with respect to this
come on what is happening here like what
what would you what would you say
well i'd say i think it's so beautiful i
mean i think
it's not that the thing is it's not that
you know we're each having our own
experience and there's consistency among
what those experiences are it sort of
sounds like that but i actually believe
there are kind of different levels of
our experience and and i think many
traditions
seem to attest to the same kinds of
thing i'm not sure it's all one mountain
people say that i think it's a mountain
range personally so to speak so that
different spiritual traditions have
slight different emphases and stuff but
there's a lot of congruence you know
that i just think this is real that
we've got this
level on which we normally experience
things in which we're socialized into
and conditioned into where we feel that
we are a separate self and the world is
out there and i just think that it
actually is true
that there's another level of our
reality
where
the somehow the separate self is
inactive and we feel we're more
part of what seems to be outside us that
we sort of belong to it and it belongs
to us and we're not so separate from it
and it's a decisive shift and
i think it's sufficiently widely
reported in the traditions and here and
there in literature people
getting to this level by one means or
another suddenly dropping into it where
they just feel
not so separate
from
what would seem to be
separate to them and external to them
number one and number two
it goes even deeper there's underneath
that there's
this
reality again of our experience that we
can get to
where we sort of somehow see that
things don't have the solidity they seem
to have and that actually they're empty
and what that means it can be understood
in a number of different ways i just
feel
convinced by now that
these are
real human experiences and they're not
separately induced in each case it's
more like in each case what obscures
them
is
somehow
blown away or blown open or temporarily
suspended or
punctured it's more like that that's
reality
oneness and emptiness are actual
features
of
i sort of think somehow the way things
really are
and it's just obscured by our ordinary
way of construing reality and these
practices and be it something that pops
in the middle of an ayahuasca experience
or five meow dmt or suddenly a couple of
students might have done that and
had something like this you know
big gun that one
right
right
big and fast i gather right
yeah yeah
man well i've never done it but you know
i think in kensho
it's not like the practice is inducing
an experience i don't see it that way
it's more like the practice is
allowing us to release something
and when that is released
naturally this other stuff becomes clear
yeah it's
it's it's an observation
well but not the last part but i think
what you're in some respects alluding to
this
idea that
our realities are
constructed in a way
by
everything
around us this reality being
filtered through
a reducing valve of sorts right to use
aldous huxley's term
and
this seems like some
hand wavy
or it might seem like some really hand
wavy spiritual stuff to
a lot of people listening but there's
actually a great ted talk i want to
recommend from
a cognitive scientist named donald
hoffman h-o-f-f-m-a-n
he is
faculty at uc irvine and a recipient of
the trolland award of the us national
academy of sciences this is a legitimate
scientist is a ted talk called do we see
reality as it is and i highly recommend
it to folks i put it in my newsletter
and fibo friday and gave some time code
points for people you can kind of hop
ahead i want to say 10 minutes or so to
get to the
the meat and potatoes of it
but
he makes a very similar point and he's
running computer science simulations and
using a totally different
toolkit
for inquiry
but arriving at perhaps what is a very
very similar conclusion and that is like
we are operating within a construction
and these things that we think of as
solid these things that we think of as
real
are more like icons on a desktop
computer
they're representations that allow us to
interact with something far
different
so it makes sense to me that one way
one explanation or description of these
ken shows experiences would be okay
this is kind of just what naturally
happens if you temporarily remove
the
gating mechanisms of your perception so
that more of the raw data hits you
right
i think that's very good i i just
recently read his book the case against
reality oh that's nice
which is a sort of detailed dive it's
not it's not too long it's very readable
he writes well you know it's a dive into
that realm and absolutely
i'll tell you though the one thing that
i feel i mean that's a really helpful
really helpful way to to come at it
the only thing though that it doesn't
necessarily sort of account for
or quite cover is
why does it feel so amazing
why does it feel so good you know it's
not just we see it differently you see
the thing about this non-dual experience
and it does have different flavors by
the way different comes in certain
varieties so the one that i described
earlier that's not the only way it can
show up it has this weird
property this kind of experience
that we are profoundly implicated in it
we don't just see it
in a way we can only see it when we
discover
that we're part of it
it's unlike other things we see you can
look at a tree from six inches away you
can take three steps back you still look
at the tree of course it looks a bit
different you could walk 100 feet away
and again it looks different but you're
still seeing it
this isn't like that you can only see it
when we discover
we're part of it
and so that i find really
wonderful that in other words in using
donald hoffman's approach we'd have to
sort of
say that
if we're using that kind of a frame to
look at what happens in kenshiro it's
discovering that we're made of the same
code as everything else kind of thing
whatever the raw data is
we're made of it too
if you see what i mean do you get what i
mean like oh i totally do no no you're
you're you're one and the same yeah i i
totally totally understand what you're
saying
absolutely yeah you're not
looking at the ocean you're one of the
drops in the ocean so to speak yeah yeah
exactly exactly and you know to really
have that as a vivid personal experience
it's just profoundly
benevolent and sort of
i feel it's the sort of ultimate healing
in a way i don't mean that
we'll be instantly healed by it of all
our trauma and all our dynamics that are
unhelpful etc but man it'll move things
along
and give us
all kinds of help in our healing journey
here here well i think that is
a beautiful
place to begin our
initial descent
since uh you also have a big evening
ahead of you and a big day
tomorrow this has been so much fun i
expected it would be and i'm glad
that you were so game
to
to to go into uncharted waters with me
so thank you for for playing along
you know i wanted to share something
super random with you also because you
mentioned pardon my greek
so
you know how we say in english it's all
greek to me
well yes i was in greece at one point
and
i asked them i said what do you say
when
you want to use an expression like that
because you can't say it's all greek to
me because you speak greek and they go
oh yes
which means it's all chinese to me so in
greece they say it's all chinese to me
and apologies to any greek friends if i
screwed up that pronunciation but i feel
like all of this is much less greek to
me after
getting your help
walking through a lot of it certainly
still quite a lot of
mystery and many many questions but
very grateful
that you were willing to take the time
to dance this dance with us again
well i'm i'm truly humbled and honored
and very very happy to get this chance
to talk with you again and
you're an exceptional conversationalist
and interviewer truly i mean i suppose
that's no surprise to anybody
but really you really honest wonderful
thank you
i only see the words
that's my own work that's my own work to
do so i appreciate you saying that and
it really means a lot and i encourage
people to
go to mountaincloud.org
that is a good jumping off point i i
suppose for
many many resources and many things that
you're up to so mountaincloud.org we'll
link to all these in the show notes and
henry's
memoir which describes his own journey
in detail is one blade of grass subtitle
finding the old road of the heart a zen
memoir henry is there anything else that
you would like to mention
instagram is at mountain cloud zen
center if people want to check that out
anything else that you would like to
suggest people check out or anything at
all that you'd like to say or suggest or
ask before we close up i might just
mention we got another site
originallove.org
where we're running a program called
original love which is like a
broad approach to meditation that
includes
approaches to awakening but other stuff
too i think it's more
has more attention to the sort of
healing side of meditation as well as
the awakening side so that's something
that i would just mention and
thanks to kevin again for
encouraging this and thanks to you very
very sincere thanks to you tim it's
great to connect with you i hope you
feel a bit better how do you feel
actually now thank you you know i i feel
emotionally much better my throat is
super sore but i'm uh
i'm welcoming the throat soreness
more than i was more than i was two
hours ago so that's a step in the right
direction
and i think i'm just gonna take a hot
bath and watch some disney shorts or
something i really need one of those
nights i think uh
and
i'm looking forward to it and
originallove.org
people should check it out we'll put it
right at the top of the show notes so
tim.log slash podcast if you just search
zen or
shukman s-h-u-k-m-a-n
or henry for that matter i'm sure they
will pop
right up
and henry once again thank you so much
for taking the time i really really
appreciate it
well not at all huge thanks to you and
to everybody listening
until next time
thank you for tuning in
hey guys this is tim again just one more
thing before you take off and that is
five bullet friday would you enjoy
getting a short email from me every
friday that provides a little fun before
the weekend between one and a half and
two million people subscribe to my free
newsletter my super short newsletter
called five bullet friday easy to sign
up easy to cancel it is basically a half
page that i send out every friday to
share the coolest things i've found or
discovered or have started exploring
over that week it's kind of like my
diary of cool things it often includes
articles i'm reading books i'm reading
albums perhaps gadgets gizmos all sorts
of tech tricks and so on that gets sent
to me by my friends including a lot of
podcast guests and these strange
esoteric things end up in my field and
then i test them and then i share them
with you so if that sounds fun again
it's very short a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend something to think about
if you'd like to try it out just go to
tim.blog friday type that into your
browser tim.log slash friday drop in
your email and you'll get the very next
one thanks for listening
this episode is brought to you by
givewell i love these guys donating
money to help other people is wonderful
but how can you be confident that your
donations are actually doing things are
they improving or saving lives
effectively it can be really hard to
parse you can do weeks of research to
find the charities that are out there
what programs they run what their admin
overhead is how effective blah blah blah
on and on it can take forever i know
from experience doing the research is
really hard
or you could simply visit givewell.org
for a short vetted list of the charities
they found to be best per dollar in
donations at saving or improving lives
givewell spends more than twenty
thousand hours each year researching
charitable organizations and only
recommends a few of the highest impact
evidence-backed charities they've found
they do all this without any sign-up
fees without taking a cut of your tax
deductible donation givewell wants to
empower as many donors as possible to
make informed decisions about their
donations so give well is free i've
recommended givewell.org for a while now
and donations from listeners of this
podcast that's you guys amount now to
roughly 483
399.27 so close to 500 000
which is incredible so first and
foremost thanks to everyone who has
donated in total more than 50 000 people
have used givewell to donate as
effectively as possible and rigorous
evidence suggests that these donations
will save tens of thousands of lives and
improve the lives of millions more so go
right now to givewell.org and when you
make your first donation your gift will
be matched up to 250
this matching offer is good for as long
as the funds last so it's time sensitive
and is a great opportunity to multiply
your impact which is something i always
look for how can i get the maximum
multiplicative effect out of my dollars
that i give
to participate just go to givewell.org
and when you get to check out pick
podcast and enter tim ferriss show it's
that simple so one more time get your
first donation matched to 250 at
givewell.org be sure to select podcast
and tim ferriss show at checkout
this episode is brought to you by
layered superfood founded by big wave
surfer laird hamilton and volleyball
champion gabby reese layered superfood
that's l-a-i-r-d delivers high impact
fuel to help you get through your
busiest days and i know these two people
they walk the walk i love their new
aloha oat mac you heard me right aloha
oatmak superfood creamer i use the
unsweetened version made from real
plant-based ingredients including
organic oats macadamia nuts that's where
the oat mac comes from avocado oil and
aquaman aquamin is a natural source of
seaweed-derived calcium with 72 minerals
and trace amounts layered creamers can
really optimize your daily coffee or tea
ritual i use them all the time and a 10
bag will last you a long time for a
limited time layered superfood is
offering you guys my listeners 20 off
when you use code tim
20 at checkout that's t-i-m-t
visit
lairdsuperfood.com tim to see some of my
favorite products and learn more again
that's lairdsuperfood.com
tim l-a-i-r-d layered superfood.com and
use code tim20 for 20 off of your order
layeredsuperfood.com
tim promo code tim 20.
[Applause]
you